do your past present and future all
exist right now are you watching this
video being born and lying on your
deathbed at this very moment
surprisingly the answer could be yes but
how can that be what does that even mean
how does time work the block
Universe imagine the universe like a
child painting pictures on paper each
picture shows everything that's
happening in the universe in a single
moment with each new moment all kinds of
things occur everywhere people are born
and die Galactic Civilizations expand
you miss the bus and our universe kid
makes a new picture that replaces the
old one in this way you get something
like a movie Only the moment we're in
right now is real the past is what
happened before now it's gone the future
is still to come and hasn't been drawn
yet this is kind of how time feels right
each moment being replaced by the next
one the past is far behind us the future
doesn't exist but what if time is
something else what if the universe kit
has already finished all its drawings
and stacks them on top of each other
this way we get a block a block of time
that contains the whole history of the
universe all moments that have ever
existed or will ever exist but in this
blog in this stack of moments the past
the present and the future are equally
real and exist at the same time this
feels wrong the only things that we
perceive as real are those things
happening now how can the past and
future be real right now the problem is
that according to the theory of
relativity they kind of have to be
heavily simplified relativity says that
time and space are not separated but one
connected space time when you move
through space space you're also moving
through the block this means time passes
differently for different people
depending on how they move through space
relative to each other and this also
means that what someone perceives as now
is a certain cut along the block a cut
that will depend on how fast they're
moving so what you think is Now is
really only your now there are many
different Nows in the universe and all
of them are equally real this also means
there's no Universal past or future
okay this is a lot how does this
work imagine three alien spaceships a
million light years away the first one
just hovers in space not moving relative
to you you both experience the same now
the same present if you had a magical
instantaneous internet connection you
could do a video call right now and chat
about alien things the second spaceship
is flying away from us at 30 km a second
about three times f faster than a human
rocket it's moving differently through
the block of time than you are which
means it's now is different from yours
with the magical internet the aliens can
talk to your ancestors in 1924 when
Humanity was discovering the first
galaxies outside the Milky Way the third
spaceship wants to visit Earth and is
flying towards you at 30 km a second
moving at the opposite angle of the
second ship through the block of time it
experiences yet another now with the
magical internet the aliens can talk to
your descendants in the year
2,124 when Humanity has already built
cities on Mars and Venus okay so we have
three different Nows so which one is
correct well that's the problem
relativity is based on one powerful
principle Cosmic democracy the fact that
the point of view of all observers in
the universe is equally valid all those
Nows have to be equally real but if this
is the case your past present and and
your future all have to exist at the
same time right now because for the
different aliens they all happen in
their present this means that the
distinction between the past the present
and the future is an illusion the
universe is not a bunch of things
evolving through time like in a movie
but a static Block in which the past the
present and the future all coexist and
are real how can that be well think
about a galaxy outside the Observer
Universe too far away to ever visit or
see but even if you can't get there and
don't see it it's still real the future
might be the same but if the past is not
far behind us and the future actually
exists then there is no movie things
don't happen in the universe the
universe just is like a frozen block of
dead Cosmic ice with everything that
will ever happen already written and
decided is the future or already written
if all times coexist and are equally
real then the future has to be already
written but that's not how you
experience things it feels like you can
mold your future with your decisions it
really feels like you're free to choose
to stop watching YouTube to not miss the
bus but if the future is set in stone
you can't decide anything so are your
choices an illusion well maybe maybe
your free will is The Mirage and maybe
you missing the bus was already
predetermined at the Big Bang so feel
free to continue
watching except Quantum stuff is ruining
everything again Quantum processes can't
be predicted not even in principle not
because we're silly and don't know how
to do it according to quantum physics
Quantum particles are intrinsically
random for example if you have a
radioactive atom it could Decay at any
moment in the next second or in in the
next million years we can calculate the
probability that it will Decay tomorrow
but no Oracle in the universe will ever
be able to tell you with absolute
certainty if it will do so or not but
Quantum particles can change the World
Imagine a radioactive element randomly
decays and causes a genetic mutation in
a nearby mammal and then many
generations later that mutation has led
to a weird mix of duck and mammal that
makes no sense or the atom decays a day
later and the weird creature will never
exist if quantum stuff is really
uncertain the future can't be set in
stone but if the future is an untold
story it can't be real in the same way
as the past is so what happens when
uncertain things like the decay of our
atom become real is that moment the
present is this now but before we saw
that Cosmic democracy makes it
impossible to Define an absolute now
what's going on here it turns out that
for every individual object you an alien
an atom the past the present and the
future are always well defined your
death will always happen after your
birth never before and never at the same
time now you are clearly between your
birth and your death so for you at least
now makes perfect sense if we don't play
tricks like going to the other side of
the universe and using aliens in funny
ways to find out what now means things
again start to look ordered and nice and
individual Nows seem to exist can we do
something with them let's return to our
block Universe maybe the block does not
contain the future and maybe we just
imagined it wrong maybe the block is
just the past and a thin layer on the
surface is the present that surface is
not smooth but bumpy and uneven it's
been made by joining countless
individual Nows each experienced by by
someone or something in the universe
each equally real and valid and all
observers do their bit so Cosmic
democracy is still true as new things
happen and uncertain Things become
certain radioactive atoms Decay new
species of mammals arise people miss the
bus the Border moves upwards creating
new time in the universe instead of a
frozen block of time with a future that
has already been written the block is
growing and things happen you can again
decide your future maybe leave earlier
so you won't miss the bus what is real
then let's recap we started with time as
a movie one now after another where only
the current now was real then we found
out that because of Relativity there are
multiple Nows all of them real somehow
which could mean that we're living in a
frozen block Universe where things don't
happen and you don't really have free
will and we ended up with a kind of
growing block univers where time passes
and the future is open so which is
correct what is real the present the
past are the dinosaurs as real as you
are right now what do the aliens on the
other corner of the universe think about
all this to be honest no one knows what
we've learned are two possibilities to
describe time but they're not the only
ones some scientists think that the idea
of now only makes sense near you but not
in the universe as a whole others think
that time itself doesn't even exist that
the whole concept is an illusion of our
human mind and others think that time
does exist but that it's not a
fundamental feature of the universe
rather time may be something that
emerges from a deeper level of reality
just like heat emerges from the motion
of individual molecules or life emerges
from the interactions of lifeless
proteins we could go on but aren't you
about to to miss the
bus the concept of time is abstract and
Elusive possibly Beyond complete human
comprehension fortunately there's a vast
world of things we do understand about
the universe that you can explore right
now thanks to our friends at
brilliant.org brilliant has thousands of
bite-sized Hands-On lessons in science
maths technology and beyond their latest
course introduction to probability offer
is a practical guide to interpreting the
world you'll Master the tools of chance
risk and prediction while learning to
model real world situations and running
simulations of everything from election
results to who will win the next World
Cup they even have a lesson on the past
and future where you'll explore how past
outcomes may not reliably forecast
future events in the ever evolving
tapestry of time and since it's always a
good time to learn we've created an
entire series of lessons in
collaboration ation with brilliant to
take your scientific knowledge to the
next level these lessons let you further
explore the topics in our most popular
videos from rabiz and mamalian
Metabolism to climate science and supern
noi think of each one as an interactive
one-on-one version of a cazar video to
get hands- on with kts gazar lessons and
explore everything brilliant has to
offer you can start your free 30-day
trial by signing up at brilliant.org
nutshell and for kts gazak viewers the
first 200 people to use our link get 20%
off an annual membership once their
trial
ends H our shop has grown so much over
the years thanks to all of you now it's
time to move our precious products to a
bigger warehouse but should our tiny BBS
really have to carry all those
boxes no help us out and grab a box in
our biggest sale ever but first we'll
give you a little
tour here you can see how our posters
are actually created and this is how our
enamel pins are made but watch out there
are some pretty creepy and dangerous
things in here as well and this is where
the deals are crafted they'll only be
available for a short time and as long
as supplies last so head over to the
shop now the birds really appreciate
your
[Music]
help